-Dans sa famille,
on brille à la fois dans le foot
et la politique.
Lui a d'abord préféré
le ballon rond,
mais il préside aujourd'hui
la délégation aux outre-mer
à l'Assemblée.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Davy Rimane.
-Bonjour.
-Le premier jour
d'un député à l'Assemblée,
c'est forcément un moment
qui mêle un peu de fierté
et d'émotion.
Sauf que pour vous,
les choses ne sont pas
forcément bien passées.
Ca a été marqué
par un incident,
que vous avez raconté
en prenant la parole
dans l'hémicycle, à l'occasion
d'un débat sur la politique
d'immigration de la France.
*-Suite à mon élection
au mois de juin,
je suis arrivé à l'Assemblée,
je n'avais pas le badge.
Je suis arrivé aux portes
de l'Assemblée. Pour me renseigner,
je ne pouvais pas entrer,
j'ai sonné. Une personne sort.
Je lui ai dit "bonjour".
Elle a répondu.
La 1re chose qu'elle dit,
avant que je puisse m'exprimer :
"Monsieur, les livraisons,
c'est de l'autre côté."
On m'a tout de suite ramené à quoi ?
A ma couleur de peau.
-Vous dites
que vous n'avez pas été blessé
par cet incident,
que vous en avez souri.
Pourquoi ?
-Parce que j'avais déjà été marqué
par ça dans mon enfance,
ma jeunesse.
Je me suis construit avec ça.
-Vous en avez pris l'habitude ?
-Oui, ce n'était pas nouveau,
mais ça m'a permis
d'être un trait d'union
par rapport au débat
sur l'immigration
et ce que peut ressentir
une personne qui arrive
à un endroit
qui ne ressemble pas
à celui chez qui elle arrive.
Donc, le regard
qu'on porte sur autrui
est extrêmement important.
Donc ne pas sentir
que nous soyons...
rejetés au travers du regard,
c'est important.
-Le fait que ça soit arrivé
dans une institution
comme l'Assemblée,
qu'on considère
comme la maison des Français,
ça a une signification politique
particulière ?
-Ca veut dire que nos institutions
encore n'ont pas fait...
le deuil de cette histoire
de la France, parce que,
au travers de nos institutions,
ça veut dire que la discrimination
suinte toujours. C'est pas normal.
-C'est-à-dire
qu'elle prend naissance
au coeur de nos institutions ?
-Souvent, je prends l'exemple
de l'élaboration des lois.
Les territoires d'outre-mer
sont toujours gérés à la marge,
à la fin de la loi. On dit :
"Pour les territoires d'outre-mer,
"ça va être légiféré
par ordonnance ou par décret."
Il n'y a pas de débats,
pas de discussions,
pas de prise en compte des réalités.
Au coeur de l'élaboration de la loi,
tous les territoires ne sont pas
logés à la même enseigne.
-C'est l'un des moteurs
de votre engagement. Vous dites que
souvent,
l'Etat tolère outre-mer des choses
qu'il ne tolère pas en métropole
sur des choses comme l'accès
à l'eau, à l'électricité.
Ca vous motive ?
Lutter contre une forme
de discrimination,
qui est plus territoriale ?
-Un exemple simple :
le taux de chômage.
Il avoisine 9 %
dans l'Hexagone.
Nos territoires,
de façon structurelle,
avoisinent toujours
entre 24 et 25 %.
L'autre chiffre qui est déterminant
dans la situation :
dans nos territoires, quasiment
1 actif sur 2 ne fait rien.
Il n'est pas au chômage
ou en formation.
Il ne travaille pas. Tout le monde
n'est pas sur les radars
concernant le chômage.
Ca veut dire
que prenez ces chiffres-là,
ramenés à l'échelle de l'Hexagone,
le branle-bas de combat est déclaré
pour sortir de cette situation.
Regardez les efforts faits
sur l'Hexagone
pour passer bientôt
au plein emploi.
Mais on part d'un delta de 9 %.
Le plein emploi,
c'est qu'on arrive 5 %.
Il y a 4 % de marge à faire,
alors que nos territoires,
c'est 24-25 %.
Vous avez 20 points.
Et quand on connaît le tissu
économique et social,
ça va être très compliqué.
-Lors de votre 1re candidature
aux législatives en 2017,
parmi vos adversaires,
vous aviez votre tante,
Juliana Rimane,
ancienne députée de Guyane
de 2002 à 2007. Si on remonte
à la génération d'avant,
vous avez un de vos grands-pères
qui a été maire de Kourou,
une des principales villes
de Guyane, 42 ans.
Eustase Rimane.
On a l'impression que la politique
est dans l'ADN familial.
Comment vous l'expliquez ?
-C'est une fierté.
Mon grand-père a oeuvré beaucoup
au développement
de la ville de Kourou,
pendant 42 ans.
Il était un maire de droite,
la famille du RPR,
proche de Jacques Chirac,
et pour autant,
il a fait beaucoup dans le social
par rapport aux réalités
qui l'entouraient.
C'est là son intelligence :
répondre aux doléances
de ses concitoyens
et amener des réponses positives
plus souvent que rarement.
-Il y a une différence
entre elle, lui et vous.
Eux étaient engagés à droite.
Vous, à gauche.
-C'est ça.
-Vos valeurs de gauche,
qui vous les a transmises ?
-Ma grand-mère paternelle,
avec qui
à un moment donné
j'ai vécu quelques années.
Elle m'a transmis
ces valeurs humaines :
le respect,
l'acceptation de l'autre,
même s'il vous ressemble pas.
Elle a arrêté l'école,
elle avait 11 ans,
parce qu'il fallait
qu'elle s'occupe...
A l'époque,
il fallait s'occuper de la maison,
des petites soeurs,
des frères.
Pour autant,
elle avait une sagesse,
une approche de la vie au quotidien.
C'est pour ça que pour moi,
c'était une très grande dame.
Et si je suis là aujourd'hui,
c'est en grande partie grâce à elle.
-Longtemps, vous avez porté
un regard très critique
sur la classe politique.
J'ai retrouvé une citation
de vous en 2016, juste avant
que vous ne vous engagiez.
"On laisse les politiques
"voter des lois à la con
qui ne valent pas un kopek."
Qu'est-ce que vous reprochiez
à la politique
et aux hommes politiques ?
-La non-prise en compte
des réalités des territoires.
Nos territoires ultramarins...
Ce sont mes mots.
Je qualifie ça de scandale.
Depuis 46,
nous sommes passés en département,
sortis de colonie,
passés en département français,
qui devait s'appeler
l'assimilation,
mais qui est devenu
la départementalisation,
avec des successions
d'évolutions de lois.
On a l'impression
d'être restés figés dans le temps
à différents niveaux.
Il y a un problème.
Les lois qui ont été votées
pour l'application
sur nos territoires,
ne valaient pas un clou.
On nous a mis dans une situation
qui est dramatique.
Il ne faut pas qu'on ait peur
d'utiliser les bons mots,
la bonne sémantique,
qui pourrait heurter.
Ca doit faire prendre conscience
qu'on doit sortir
de ce système-là,
de cette situation
où hommes, femmes et enfants
sont en grande souffrance.
-Ce regard vous a éloigné
de la politique à vos débuts.
Vous avez préféré vous engager
dans le syndicalisme chez EDF,
en Guyane. C'est là
où vous étiez salarié.
C'est comme ça qu'au printemps 2017,
vous êtes devenu
l'un des porte-parole de ce grand
mouvement social qui a bloqué
la Guyane
pendant plusieurs semaines.
Ce qui est surprenant,
c'est que ce mouvement,
il était très hostile
à la politique. Le mot d'ordre,
c'était : "Pas de politique".
C'est ce qui s'est passé là qui
vous a convaincu de vous engager ?
-Oui, c'est un moment déterminant
pour moi,
parce que c'est là
qu'on prend conscience, en fait,
que c'est dans la sphère politique
que tout se décide.
On peut être en dehors
de la sphère politique,
on participe aux activités,
aux aides, tout ce qu'on veut,
au quotidien,
mais la sphère de décision,
c'est dans le monde politique.
C'est en ce sens-là
que voulant oeuvrer
à ce changement tant attendu,
voulu par beaucoup d'entre nous,
il était tout à fait normal
que je m'y engage
et qu'à ma manière,
j'apporte ma pierre à l'édifice.
-Vous vous engagez.
Ca n'a pas fonctionné
aux 1res législatives.
Vous vous êtes présenté deux fois,
et en 2022,
là, vous êtes élu.
Mais alors,
depuis votre élection,
on sent
que vous êtes un peu frustré.
Vous avez expliqué :
"J'ai de la colère,
"de la frustration.
J'aurais tant souhaité
"faire plus, mais je vois
les limites de l'exercice."
Ca veut dire que
vous vous sentez inutile
en tant que député à l'Assemblée ?
-Quand vous mangez des 49.3
régulièrement, vous vous dites :
"A quoi je sers ?"
Au-delà de ça,
le travail parlementaire,
il est devenu compliqué,
parce que dans la Ve République,
telle qu'elle est constituée,
l'exécutif a la main sur tout.
C'est nous, parlementaires...
Depuis 2017, le parlementaire
ne peut plus être exécutif.
Pour moi,
le parlementaire cherche sa place
dans cet échiquier politique,
ce fonctionnement
de la Ve République.
C'est pour ça
qu'il y a des frustrations,
lorsqu'on a la volonté
que les choses bougent,
on a la frustration
que les choses prennent du temps
ou qu'on n'est pas forcément écoutés
et que les décisions prises
ne sont pas en adéquation
avec les réalités
des territoires concernés.
Et puis,
il y a cette colère aussi,
cette colère
que je veux bonifier,
pour permettre à nos territoires
d'évoluer positivement.
On ne peut plus cautionner ça.
Aujourd'hui,
concrètement,
le fait qu'on veuille
légiférer sans nous,
qu'on prenne des décisions
ou que l'on veuille faire des choses
sans nous concerter,
ça veut dire
que tout ce qui va sortir in fine
sera contre nous.
-Vous présidez quand même
la délégation aux outre-mer
à l'Assemblée.
Ca ne vous donne pas
un levier politique
pour peser sur les décisions,
pour avoir
une vraie influence ?
-Oui et non. En tant
que président de délégation...
La délégation n'est pas
une commission.
Elle n'a pas les mêmes pouvoirs.
Néanmoins, on essaie,
au travers de cette délégation,
de mener des travaux à bien
et de démontrer objectivement
les nécessités de bouger
sur différentes lignes,
chose qui n'est pas simple.
Il y a ce jeu de discussions
qu'on essaie d'avoir,
d'influence, avec l'exécutif,
pour qu'il puisse entendre,
comprendre et mettre en oeuvre
les bonnes décisions.
J'ai envie de dire ça comme ça,
mais après, on part de loin.
Ce n'est pas simple. Il faut avoir
la capacité d'écouter tout le monde,
de discuter et d'essayer
de prendre des décisions
qui puissent rassembler le maximum.
-Pour peser.
Je voulais quand même
vous entendre sur un événement
dont on a pas mal parlé
dans les médias en septembre 2022,
au début de cette législature :
le premier match de foot
de l'équipe parlementaire,
de l'équipe de députés
de l'Assemblée nationale.
On en a beaucoup parlé,
parce qu'à l'époque,
les membres de l'équipe
députés de gauche
ont refusé de jouer
aux côtés des députés
du RN.
Tous, sauf un.
On vous voit sur ces images.
Vous,
vous avez tenu à jouer.
Pourquoi ?
-Tous les jours,
nous avons des concitoyens
qui sont confrontés
à différentes situations.
Comme je l'ai rappelé,
en tant que député, je...
On se côtoie régulièrement
dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée,
on échange.
On ne peut ne pas être d'accord.
Pour moi, le terrain de football,
un lieu sportif,
ne doit pas être
le lieu d'une expression politique
de la sorte. C'est mon avis.
-C'est celui de l'ancien
entraîneur qui s'est occupé
de gamins en Guyane ?
-Je suis éducateur sportif.
Donc, pour moi,
le sport doit rassembler
et même au travers
des débats qu'on peut avoir
sur des postures différentes,
ces discussions peuvent amener
l'un ou l'autre
à évoluer sur sa position initiale.
Je crois en ce débat contradictoire.
Il n'est pas nécessaire
d'avoir des postures fermées.
Je crois en la force
de la discussion
entre les hommes et les femmes.
-Le foot occupe
une place importante.
Vous avez deux frères
qui ont été professionnels.
Vous avez joué en Nationale 2.
Vous rêviez d'être joueur pro ?
-Rêvé, non.
Ca faisait partie des possibilités.
Mais après, une grande fierté
de voir que mon grand frère
a ouvert la porte à mes frères
à Laval, à Sedan,
qui ont pu à un moment donné
goûter à ce niveau-là
et rendre leur expérience
sur le territoire guyanais.
Le football, le sport
fait partie intégrante
de nos vies.
-On va passer
à notre quiz, à présent.
Le principe :
je vais commencer une phrase
et vous devez la terminer.
C'est bon ?
On y va.
Les députés devraient s'inspirer
du football pour... ?
-Se rassembler.
-Justement,
ce dont on parle.
-Se rassembler
et avoir une force
de cohésion collective.
-Ceux qui découvrent
que je viens de Guyane
me demandent souvent... ?
-Comment c'est. Il y a...
-Une méconnaissance ?
-Totale. Souvent, je leur dis...
J'ai invité plusieurs collègues
à venir en Guyane, à venir découvrir
ce territoire
qui a beaucoup à montrer,
et démontrer qu'un avenir radieux
peut être possible pour nous.
-Enfin,
si mes enfants se lancent
en politique, je... ?
-Leur dirai :
"Réfléchissez bien avant d'y aller."
-Pourquoi ?
-Parce que c'est un monde
extrêmement hypocrite et méchant.
-Ca ne donne pas envie.
-Il faut être bien armé.
-Vous ne les dissuaderiez pas,
mais vous...
-Non. Je leur dirais surtout
d'être une personne aboutie
humainement, complètement.
-Avant de se lancer.
-Au-delà de l'âge, c'est par rapport
aux événements de la vie.
On arrive abouti par rapport
aux choses qu'on a traversées
et on pourra mener des combats.
Si on n'est pas abouti,
il ne faut pas y aller.
-Merci, Davy Rimane.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...